τάξι και αρχγόναστητνομία αμε και φονάε για τον το σύλλα πάννται των τορναρίτη για κγιαγια
κάτι καπνα που δρα σε μια αποθήκι που πίστευκαιότε δικάμου τουτος το οποία ν ήταν
καπνά τελικάταπτού το φιτόχομα ακου τώαακού το χειρότερο τώρα μετά που κιο τρεις ημέρες εγώ
κάθομε στο με χαζεί μου τοαπάει και πα το τραπέδε να θονται πιο αστυνομική ο
ένα σε πολλά φιλόσμου κι άλλω ετο ιμέ κάθε το για και έχατο τηλέφωνο μο
προστάμου έτσι και τε ένα μήνυμα καλησπέρα φίλα που πως είσαι κατι τέχτειών και ήταν
η φάτησα του γενικό εκτή και δεν τηνώαστε τον ομικόο οποίος τους αττομικός ήταν στις
σύσκεψη υπάρχει όνομα και πίθεσα λοιπόν κα έχαμε έτ αθροσ πι αντιλέτο έσι ναρεμα ενώ
ενικός εναι ρ ένα ιμο προκτές εθένα να σεγάλει φυλακή σημείωσ ότι τούτος ανθρωπος μετα
σεμονές του τότε εκούχτησαν και ότι καραλαμπίδου ότωνα και πι καις πιόκα ναμσαν τώ κλέφτης
απατεώνας και τι εκατάφερε έκλαισε πο τορποστάσεις οτούτος άνθρωπο ρκιλέ έκανε ντώα τα πράματα συνεχώς
δλαδή δεναφήννεν κανέα να δουλεύσει στε τ δημόσεση αλυπηρεσία αι όταν σέβαλλε το μάτιι θέλε
να ε ξολοθρέψε και ότανε περάσανι καιρί και εξι εκινής αν ίδιαπληκτισμή μαζί μπου για
γραφατού και γραφέ μου καείναι μια στιγμή και λέει εγ με τον κύρο τωρ ναρίτει
μιλούσαν μόνο μόνο λεκτικά έγραψε των το πράγμα ενώ τα γεννικόσα ενεκτί να παςπελάριο ανθρώπος
λοιπό εμέέναν και ο πουμε πρασε παραπάνω που λλά ξέρεις τηήταν τώαιμετό ναιδηλαδή αντιν αρτ
να πο πίσει γνώμη να απόπίχριστόφορε γάρε εμιούσαε μέχρι που το πύρα τούρτα ρπα στο
γραφείω του καιρί ντεερών καιρί και εσβήσαμε των τούρτα και στελεμου καιμήνυμα ντα πονα σουμιλώ
μετά για να απαλαλεής ότι σβύνεις τούρτς μετά που περάσαν κάποια χρόνια λοιπόν εγώ καιο
πουμε πήρα ι εμπάρα πολύ είναι τι ότι όταν πξιςδλαδή επέξε ε δούλεψα πολλά σκληρα
ένα καθαρισότο νομαμο πάρά πολλά σκυτερά πέρασα που πολύ μπονών που πολύ πώρα σο εξηγήσω
πως θαίνε κάρασα δ